first off let me just I am
truly this is the most excited I have
been about a podcast this is the most
excited I've been about a guest this
person I have been a psycho fan of for
22 years uh she's my celebrity crush and
my high school bully
you know he's like completely deep in
trauma there's no way I could avoid it
of course there I did bully one person
first of all Kate Siegel is here you
know her from the brilliant shows uh
Haunting of Hill House Blythe Manor
midnight mass un unbelievable
unbelievable actress so everything you
say here I'm gonna take with a grain of
salt today
um but I mostly invited her today
because we went to high school together
and I need someone to corroborate my age
that's 100 True Whitney is telling the
truth about her age and your face looks
the same really yeah so does yours bitch
was it something about the like the
water we were drinking and I have this
theory about anxious women who have like
a lot of blood rushing all the time that
is I feel like I'm embalmed because I
only drank Diet Coke for like 20 years
yeah but I can tell you like I used to
watch people tear you down on the
internet and I was was like broke and
not a famous actress at all so nobody
listened to me but I was like that's
what she's always look like she's saying
her correct age she's just always been
famous just some of that time she was in
my high school
so okay so this is wild Kate and I have
not seen each other so we will talk
about I wanna because I do want to talk
about your career and I do want to talk
about horror because I'm obsessed I do
want to tell them the last time we saw
each other on the street this is gonna
be honestly the most mind-blowing uh day
of my life because we both have uh like
we have the same experiences but
completely different takeaways but we
both felt the same way about each other
it's just let
first of all let me just say how this is
I start over podcast asking the guest
are we friends yes
we've been friends for the whole time
yeah I know it's too cool for me 22
years that you're too cool for me this
is unbelievable okay so in height you
were the first person who was nice to me
on my first day of school we were in the
bathroom with Ashley Elder and I was
just standing there just like completely
shell shocked and terrified because I
left my other school because of death
threats I didn't know about this yeah
and you don't have to expound upon it
but it from what I understand it was
like I mean back then yeah
cyber bullying wasn't even a well this
was the beginning of it right so like
I'm as old as the hills I just turned 40
and the hills are not four years old I'm
very young and fresh to take back
um no ageism here but it was before the
internet was like a thing and so there
were like live journal pages and at my
public high school like I had had this
listen I am not an angel I am not in any
way like just a Wandering victim like I
gave as good as I got
well maybe not as good as we all in high
school I was doing my best did yeah and
like I didn't understand intimacy and so
any boy that wanted to make out with me
I was like oh that means I'm good and
talented and lovable and so oh you have
a girlfriend oops too bad so I made
enemies but what ended up happening was
they created this website called
the Kate siegelbaum truth page and it
was updated hourly about weird shit I
did in every single class
and so it was like I could go home and
just read all the ways I was disgusting
and horrible all day that I didn't even
fucking know and you didn't know who was
doing totally anonymous
and um
and there was a Wooten truth page that
did the same thing I did crash into
their sign thank you if that makes you
feel any better now I don't feel so bad
about it I do yeah no Kevin just fucked
them forever because I went and then
they started being email death threats
Anonymous and I went to the principal
because I was like a good girl in my
heart and the principal was like that's
not real the internet doesn't exist like
that's not what the internet's for it's
for like medical journals like no it
really happens it's just like you're
making this up
and so I this is when I started really
getting into drugs and I like I went
from being like a very good girl to
getting like D's and and that summer
like a good Jewish girl I went on my
like Birthright trip to Israel and I
went away from this world and for like a
month almost I had a group of friends
and for the first time in my life I was
like oh shit
the world can be different and I called
my mom from like some amazing disco Tech
and Haifa and I was like I can't fucking
go back there if you make me go back to
wootin I'll kill myself
and so my mom who was the principal of
the elementary next door to St Andrews
marched over to that private school and
she was like you have to take my
daughter this year in August they had
closed their Acceptance in February and
she was like because I run an element I
am the principal of an elementary school
and my school ends at sixth grade which
is when your school starts so and so she
kind of just like carried them into
taking me
c-a-r-e yes yes
um and then so I walked up to school at
St Andrews in their weird uniform
requirements and like oh if I may the it
was a dress code dress code which is
such an attack on poor people I did not
I did not have the money to like that's
another thing about I feel like both of
us were in high school traumatized super
insecure and projecting onto each other
because we were both kind of scared of
each other scared both terrified of of
female friendship I was terrified in
general yep I got the messaging growing
up that women are Mercurial and uh will
hurt you and emotional and dramatic and
like don't entrench with them like keep
them yeah you know keep your enemies uh
at a healthy distance also I was so like
chronically embarrassed like it's the
only way I know how to describe it
um I had like you know I was really bad
Eating Disorders at the time so I knew
that if I got too close to anyone that
eventually there would be some kind of
feedback on that no pun intended
um but uh uh or some kind of noticing of
my eating habits or lack thereof so I
would never eat lunch with everyone I
would go eat in my like four raisins in
my car because you're with your super
hot boyfriend
okay we'll get to that in a second but
like the I want you to know this is you
like kind of Trot out your your pain is
that the impression of it from the
outside was that you were the fucking
coolest that's so like you were over
High School you had matured past all of
us you were a famous model
I did QVC I walked around King of
Prussia Mall in wedding dresses but I
did a pee in the Pod catalog at 15. they
put a pregnancy belly on me and I was
like fake handmade and I love that yeah
I would literally walk around I remember
my biggest modeling gig was like the DC
Bloomingdale's I was like standing on a
block modeling pantyhose so I had to
wear a big uh uh Oxford shirt and then
just pantyhose and just stand on a block
that's very sexy and no one helps you on
or off the block that's rude by the way
yeah it's a bummer modeling is not the
best thing to do with our time like
that's not necessarily the most
satisfying no jobs but what I will say
is the informal modeling that I did do
yeah uh and I mean I'm very big on
Silver Lining everything Silver Lining
whatever step three like but it did I
think in a weird way help me with being
a comedian in confidence because you
have to walk up to strangers yes and try
to talk to them so I would have to go
like hang on the fourth floor there's a
trunk show for actress like and people
be like like no yeah no one wants to
talk to the weird Disney princess
walking around sacks yeah you know what
I mean who's like hey I'm the perfume
girl yeah it's like I'm going up to
women that are clearly divorced and
being like there's a wedding wedding
dress chunk show and they're like cool
so it's basically being like a perfume
girl or something so I really had to
like talk to strangers and charm
strangers and I ended up getting into
that when I came to LA because like
nobody would hire me with a 10-foot pole
no one would hire me with someone else's
dick is that like the same I'm not gonna
fuck you sometimes but um like could not
work until I fixed my teeth and then I
worked a lot uh wait what these are not
my real teeth I actually now know that
you do they did Dr Sam Saleh of Beverly
Hills did a great fucking job on my
veneers but I'm very open because like
some a lot I'm obsessed with you are
younger women and I'm very clear like
this is what I've had done this is the
cost do you guys want to see the former
teeth oh baby's teeth I love they're in
hush like it's out there this is a photo
of me I'm not trying to it's more that
this photo that I found of me and Kate
and my high school prom date or whatever
that was I just would like to say I
believe you were already dressing to be
in horror movies 100 that is the most
haunted lace dress that is the most
Jessica McClintock Bridal oh my dude
Jessica McClinton Chokehold she had all
of the baby blue Jessica McClintock
ribbed that I wore and returned the next
day 100 yeah but this is I was looking
at this I was like oh my gosh she was
already like a haunted haunted because
it's that same thing that happens they
say like kids who seem like they have
old souls it's because they were
traumatized at a young age I was
molested at a young age and so it's like
the trauma I can't forget it you're
pretty I know so pretty though aren't I
look at my teeth
that is I you know what's Wild I didn't
know I knew but I didn't know like you
know because like we actually had an
experience where both of us were targets
of a predator yeah and I think it's
because I do believe this that there's a
mark that's left on you when you're
traumatized like that and like they can
smell it those fucking monsters smell it
yeah and then he probably went further
with you because you have tiny teeth and
I have big teeth they're like we really
had no one to put a dick in this now
he's just like man she's so insecure
about his teeth let her know she's never
gonna make it in this town let's get
back to that juiciness it's the good
gossip for later it is such good gossip
but I do want to Circle back because I
did not know when you came into the high
school I don't believe I under knew
anything about your past no I didn't
tell anybody I think you guys know the
rumor for why I left Wooten was that I
fucked the principal the male principal
or so I guess I there was a female vice
president
did not do okay did not did not do did
not do and so I think that rumor hit St
Andrews but the actual reason why
because there was one really mean girl
whose name I totally forgot I think
she's in one of your pictures she like
gave me some shit about that
and this was before what's her face
dragged me into the office to tell me I
was over sexed because I made out with
Seth Mandel in the hallway
favorite things
high school names
they're always so ridiculous do you know
what I mean they are they're always so
dumb like anyone talking about any of
their High School people it's always
like Kelly mcgowski came over like
they're just so specific and weird we
live in Hollywood where everyone's name
has been changed oh my gosh it's so true
and in television shows it's always like
Mark Stone yes exactly you know what I
mean my husband was telling me about
Gail sassy who he grew up with and I was
like shut the fuck up these names I
can't get enough of weird high school
names and the people that had so much
power over us in high school I feel like
his name was Chad boo like you know why
was he my why was I so scared of like
Tad McGillicuddy you know I mean like
how did Sarah Crookshank oh my God I
love satisfaction I loved it Sarah but
like the funniest name like like Sarah
crook of course she's the coolest girl
in school all like she does Sarah
Crookshank like me no Sarah Crookshank
hated everyone well I played volleyball
with her I feel like I kind of that's
right you were very sporty I feel like a
basketball star Whitney coming well this
is okay let's get back to you trans to
me complimenting you about how cool I
know did we get a single like just can
we just make sure thank you so much
we've gotten everything we've needed for
today
um so you come in and it is it was like
the madman pilot you know of like the
new girl and and people there's a new
girl there's a new girl in high school
in a small school this was not a school
that I was really you know capable of
going to financially but there was like
an arrangement it was a long story and I
was sort of like came in from inside DC
like I didn't live in Potomac I didn't
live in that area and um and I had also
left and lived in Virginia for a couple
years uh and transferred back in
sophomore year so I had been new the
year before and I feel like it was like
trying to get my bearings and then I
feel like I finally did and then
literally like if you were to do like a
slo-mo shot of like the most nightmare
girl to walk in you're like acne scene
like junior year you're finally getting
your very like this bitch walks in with
that face just a good job
and you always had like a Starbucks I
did always have a Starbucks and I was
talking to a friend of ours yesterday
and I was like God had alcohol in it
your private school was crazy private
schools I tell people it was like
traffic and they don't believe me it's
so funny because no one was doing that
at Public School
I was also doing it at Public School
s this is I'm sober now so I might
because I remember the thing is and then
you're hilarious and then you're fucking
smart as shit and then you've read every
book and then you're nice it just yeah
it doesn't again yeah this is what you
give off whether you like it or not take
it because if you disagree with me
you're calling me dumb I don't want to
call you dumb you were very smart see
that's what Mr Whitman said it that's
the thing about
um when we compliment we don't take
other people's compliments that's what I
do now when someone's like no no and I'm
like so I'm blind yeah you know what I
mean I think it's just um the joy of
being called those things is the
internalizing of them of is the
believing of them and my belief is so
far from that especially at that time in
my life so it's like when you say that
I'm like no no you just don't know the
truth it's not that you're dumb it's
that I had you fooled interesting the
sort of like imposter syndrome or
wherever it was but I also think like
you know I was I was so jealous of you
and I realized yesterday when I was like
thinking about you and trying to like
deconstruct this of like you'd only be
jealous of someone who was awesome
do you know what I'm saying I also like
to take my own like side of that
equation I loved making people jealous
it made me feel valuable it made me feel
important like when I wasn't was warm
and open and vulnerable what I wanted
was jealousy interesting I thought like
I guess I thought I wanted intimacy but
I would settle for jealousy or lust
that's fascinating and do you think that
that is something that is you know
ancestral trauma inherited modeled for
you or because to me at that time I
um men's attention is all that mattered
to me just male attention like female
attention was stressful and scary and
exhausting and like didn't pay off yeah
you know I didn't have any proof that
female friendships and intimacy were
what I now believe is like just the
medicine of life being able to like have
like honest female friendships and um
at how do you feel like you got there or
at that time I do believe it was
something that was an epidemic with
basically all women I mean there's this
thing now where like Grace uh uh my
assistant former been promoted
um
when we like you know the like sort of
backlash against Anne Hathaway yeah of
like she's like a try too hard it was
like she what like yeah they this next
Generation doesn't play that shit no
they don't this girl hating other girls
that are winning that are trying no
she's like crying her yeah Instagram
handle is Stan Hathaway
they love they're like we don't play
this girl on girl bully shit like we
think she's awesome I'm so glad like it
was awful
um I think it was the only way I I
sometimes like when I have nightmares
about it it's that my entire body is
like a Searchlight and there was so much
light going there was I had no sense of
what power I had
and so
like all over because I
oh God I just said this to you and I'm
gonna do it now I'm gonna do that
horrible thing where someone talks about
what it's like to be pretty in the world
but it but it's not that it's that
I was such a disaster inside I had zero
concept of how my actions affected other
people so I would just do things
willy-nilly not to mention like I was a
little drunk a lot of the time and I
would just do things willy-nilly and
like would hurt people and then be so
confused as to why this person was
acting weird and then I would hate them
for their weird response and I would
just like ice cold gone and so it
created a Persona that had nothing to do
with like the true like lost little girl
which is so interesting because I was so
up my own ass uh with my eating disorder
and trying to get male attention and
make people jealous and just counting
calories and I was also very like
trauma when you're in high school and
you have bad skin it is true it is
traumatic you know it's like for you
know now excuse me now it sounds crazy
sorry I had pneumonia last week and it's
still flummy
um and so uh
I I didn't even
feel all that like I no one can it it
was like your children how are we
supposed to feel any of it you just came
off in the most Charming effervescent
free talented also I'm gonna say
something to you that might sound weird
I knew you were gonna make it I knew it
like I knew it she blushing I knew you
were gonna make it probably way before
you did oh my God Hollywood baby I know
a star when I see one and I've always
had this but I I knew you were gonna
fucking make it and I remember in a
weird way just being like well only one
of us can make it from which is not a
what is that like because what are the
odds that two people from one school
would both make it I when when Whitney
was picked up
I cried so hard I'm so sorry that is so
wild because it was that thought it was
like it's always going I'll always be
not Whitney
I'll always it'll always be Whitney and
I'll always just be like almost Kate
but it was Whitney oh my God like I
remember the feeling and like watching
your ascent and like oh God I'm so
embarrassed like like cyber stalking
like Google image searching you with the
premieres looking so beautiful you
hanging out with famous people your TV
show everyone talking about how smart
and funny a Creator you were and I was
just like well it's only going to happen
to one of us
so
I guess I'll sell these energy drinks
well that was a so basic which I was
selling energy drinks literally a year
before this incident happened right the
cringe of this so I'm driving down
Melrose and I see Kate on the side of
the road doing what we all do what you
do even the working actor even when
you're a working actor when I was on
punked when I was on I mean when I got a
TV show I was still
had eighty thousand dollars of debt and
student loans so I still was in the hole
like you're still broke even when you're
on TV I think a lot of people don't
understand that necessarily yeah
especially now yeah and then I had two
parents had Strokes without health
insurance and a nightmare nightmare and
then um so I got so excited to see it
wasn't even like for whatever reason in
that moment all of the past stuff like
went away of like because we were
friends underneath it like the reality
of it was we understood each other and
we liked each other well the reality is
also which we're gonna Circle back of we
were very
um
strategically pitted against each other
by one of our teachers yes in a way that
that was really sick which we'll get to
in a second but when that person was
gone it was like oh my God like this is
like and I was like lost in this
business where I was getting treated
horribly and people were so it's like
being so shitty to me and so seeing you
was just like like oh my it was like the
best feeling and I saw you and I like
ran up to you and I didn't even realize
how
that would have come off
how would you didn't work how like you
couldn't have possibly known how much
stalking of you I had done and how I was
like how the comparison in my head had
led me to believe like that it was this
and then from my point of view which
like is only my perception I am selling
I'm not even selling I'm handing out
free samples of Godiva energy drinks
nobody wants a creamy energy drink it
was so fucking gross the irony is I'm
like the only person that would actually
buy that
and then I'm eating ice out of the
container of the like the cooler because
I'm so fucking bored and hungry and you
run up um you're in your beautiful car
you're beautiful you smell like like a
Saks Fifth Avenue and that is like
Charlie girl yeah because Terry Mueller
Angel
everybody's sunflowers exactly I hope
it's here wait hold on no I've got
where's my where's my CK one did someone
steal my ck1 that's so cool Emily I have
my own I don't know what it is where's
my Tommy Boy I usually have a CK one
right there anyway so and you hugged me
and I had a mouthful of ice and I tried
to Crunch down it quickly it made a loud
noise and you were like did I just break
your jaw and I was like nope I'm just
I'm a noisy person and it was this is
right 100
and this is probably why my teeth were
so jacked because I ate ice all the time
um but I just was like like the
definition of the word cringe like I
couldn't have pictured a worse thing
because I was like I know I'm sweaty and
smelly and eating ice and like handing
an energy drink to Whitney Cummings and
I've never recovered but in my head I
know it's great in my head because I
know how to I know you're gonna make it
I'm not gonna make it but I do forever
so I'm like why she's like why that why
was that so weird like why like in my
head you're Meryl Streep oh my God so I
I always said I was like that's the next
Julia Roberts I didn't I didn't totally
know you were gonna go drama yeah like
mostly or drama and like horror which I
want to talk about in a second but also
horror and comedy are
inextricably linked about the building
the tension 100 and timing and
everything patterns and timing and I
actually think it's so much smarter to
have gone down horror and drama room
because only choice well but you it's I
had to make my own movie like no truly
fuck me with someone else's day same I
literally wrote the Whitney pilot
because after I had gone in and it
because that was at a time where you
literally could only get on television
if the executives and the head of the
network wanted to fuck you it was like
literally you were going on dates
personality auditions and you would go
in and I never I was like Molly Sims Ida
field sometimes Busy Phillips but it was
like uh Leslie Bibb and then I would be
like the funny weirdo that was like
funny in the room but was like never
gonna get it I was never I wasn't like
um what's the word like plain enough to
be the girl next door and I wasn't sexy
enough to be the sexy girl and I was
always taller than every actor so I
would go I would like get kind of close
and then the actor would come in to do a
screen test and the actor would just
come up to like here and I'd be like I'm
not getting this job I wonder if there
is an actress out there who was like
yeah it was me I was right perfect
running like right down the middle I
just like fit right in I heard that once
uh only about Robin Wright Penn for uh
Princess Bride
who like the director was like she
walked in and was like that was that's
Buttercup like that I wonder if like did
she feel that way or if she was like
I've been crawling through broken glass
to get to these auditions like I've
never met an actress who was like it was
pretty smooth for me yeah I just walked
in and it was that was that yeah it was
just Kismet or whatever you know there's
no booked at First Sight there's no it's
always a struggle it's you know but then
they want you to tell the story like
that during press like what they don't
want I have found is that they don't
want the actual story they want a
Feeling
that is You Were Somehow magically
discovered at the soda counter uh Chris
Klein for election or whatever we just
hired the actual quarterback and it was
perfect you know but I think that you I
was thinking about this over the weekend
you have like hacked the system in such
a cool way and I think I I think I think
I kind of did too in a different way
yeah I must say because most people
don't understand that when you're
signing up to be an actor let's say you
make it great let's say you're like that
all the luck you know Lighting in a
bottle the world conspires and your
talented and you work hard and
everything you spend most of your time
promoting your work it's like you are
you don't spend that much time acting
and like you are someone that actually
loves acting you're so you love you're
so good and you get to spend I spend
most of my time eight months actually
acting I was watching in the midnight
mass that that gorgeous long shot of you
guys walking and I'm like I know how
long that takes to do I know I'm like
she's just doing a fucking eight minute
take with no Cuts yeah
instead of running around on Jimmy
Kimmel there's something so Matt his
rejection is God's protection you don't
have to believe in God to you know
digest that but to me it's like you know
I I believe that the greatest actors
don't do a ton of press the more press
you do the more we know your personality
and the less we can get lost and I know
that we have to do press in order to
that ship sailed for me but like you
know I think I remember when it was like
Jennifer Lopez and when that gly shit
happened with Ben Affleck when it was
like the movie bombed because we had
seen you too much and it's also harder
to believe all of a sudden people like
they're bad actors it's like no you just
know who they are yeah like I even
though I know you even I can like watch
you even though you and um Hill House
like Theodora to me is so you that's how
I saw you in high school that's pretty
close yeah that's like how I saw it but
that was a gift like terrifying when
Mike wrote Theo
um he had me in mind and then again
Netflix made me audition like four times
for that part but we had learned
something back when I did hush I was
like I want to do her because I was so
afraid of failing I was like I need a
woman who's terrified because no matter
what I do I'm going to leak Terror onto
this screen
and so I want I was like I need to do a
final girl because it will be so
believable because I'm going to be
deeply panicked and so when he was
creating Theo and I was reading it I was
like if we do this this and this the
protections that are going to come out
in me in that kind of situation will be
there no matter what so let's lean into
that and that's I think for me the
secret of acting is like to know
yourself in a way that you know what
you're going to be like on the day and
use that choice if you're a sweater like
if you're a person who sweats and it's a
winter scene take your fucking jacket
off people do weird things all the time
just like don't fake what's leaking out
of you that is a bad actor truly
brilliant oh good like I when we do we
have all we need here so thank you
I am I that is like blowing my mind
because to me like acting is like the
only time I really do it is when I'm
like this is a part of me that I don't
normally get to show
um
or this is what I'll be on the day
insecure about my appearance like
literally the last movie I did I was
like let's make it a character choice
that she's always like worried about her
light yes because I'm going doing that
either way you're gonna do it so that's
yes you're right you make it part of the
character and that's the thing that
people will go it seems so real when you
were and I was like Yeah because it was
I was in a white hot Panic the entirety
of shooting hush that I would somehow
mess up my one choice and when I watched
that movie back I am in a white hot
panic in that movie and it works and so
it's basically a documentary basically a
documentary it was the DP chasing me
around and I was like no I can't this is
something I really want to ask you
because I feel like you and I and I can
now say this without being embarrassed
or cringing of like I am a tryhard I
want like I'm a total tryhard I think
it's cool like I'm not the person that
was that was like like I tried hard at
school I yeah want to win I want to get
the points and my motives are different
now it used to be for self-esteem now
it's kind of to show people you can
alchemize your trauma and make something
good about it yeah you know you can uh
sublimate the bad things that happen to
you and use it for good and you can
whatever make it a business Etc so
there's the motives weren't healthy
before the motives I think now are
pretty clean
um but when I first came down it was no
secret to anyone that we both really
wanted to make it yeah 100 But the irony
is that is so repellent that energy is
so repellent I was like when I first
came out here I cannot even Matt like
the oh like the like what did you how
did you besides this life hack of just
take the parts or do the things that
you're already exuding and leaking out
you know did you struggle it because I
would go in rooms and be like like I
need this job like I don't want this
like I need this oh it was the number
one feedback my reps got that I got that
was it was always like good girl not the
one for the part but if you dug harder
it's like she's a great actress but like
she's she smells like desperation like
she's desperate and I was fucking
desperate I couldn't stop it it was
never gonna stop and uh but what what
what is it what was that I love that I
want to do it so badly yeah and I don't
think there's any like you were talking
about the Hatha hate I don't think
there's anything wrong with people who
want something and go after it I have
never been able in my opinion to like be
cool be a cool girl like there is a
whole Cadre of Hollywood Cool Girl
actresses who are legitimately laid back
or else they just have their lithium
high enough that they appear that way
but
they CA they like don't like me because
I'm not that I want to talk about like
how did you get there and like okay so I
have this weird scene to do like what
would you do if you had to do this weird
scene why do you think they don't like
you
I think they know how badly I want it
and that I would kill most of them
[Laughter]
I'm getting too much therapy not to take
some responsibility like I'm clearly
giving off the thing like I think your
job is more important than than our
friendship like there are people who I
love with my heart and soul but
but yeah I I want to win yeah I'm
competitive I'm ambitious I am motivated
I am not giving up I am gonna fight
until I win or die yeah and I think
that's really uncomfortable for some
people I think so too and I think a
tenacity is like you know the weird
thing about it and this is where it's
dysmorphic and doesn't serve us is that
we both have the talent
it means we're lacking Faith 100 like I
think I would have been much more
successful much earlier and more
successful now if I could relax 100
without because to me when someone comes
in or you see it's like all your anxiety
is making me think you're not talented
or you don't think you could get this
yes you're worried you won't now I'm
thinking you can't exactly but you're
the one that doesn't think you're gonna
get this 100 and then I believe you yeah
because when you walked in I was like
she's got this job and then you lost it
for yourself by being worried you
weren't gonna get it this is yes that
could not be better put because it is
and it gets in your way all the time but
I don't think this particular
problem is solved by more attention on
it so I kind of just acknowledge it and
then I go okay it'll go away eventually
or it won't because or else it'll just
be a thing that held me back a little
bit Yeah but I'm still gonna win or I
should like play Reese Witherspoon's
part in election right like right now
I'm out looking for parts like that I'm
looking for like top level psychotic
lawyers like Annette Benning and
American Beauty I will sell this house
great great because I'm like that'll be
a really fun breakdown but this is this
is I literally told my agents I was like
I only want to play like villains like I
think that's what I'm cut out for like I
give off that energy by accident you
know just like
um scary and then I have all these
Character defects that I'm not allowed
to use in real life anymore or else it's
a relapse for me it's like I am
incredible at lying I'm very
manipulative I like I can be I have like
absolutely I feel like I have all these
super powers you know in my Arsenal that
because of my sobriety and Al-Anon ACA
Coda like I'm not allowed to use yeah
but
I have like I I'm loaded up with it and
I want to be able to like play around
with it and pay homage to them because
those were all tools that served me
really well yeah when I was younger or
kept me safe when I was younger or were
something I felt I needed like they're
my friend they're trying to protect me
yeah they're my friends and uh even
though now they're Obsolete and they
backfire on me and our liability now
even though they were superpowers then
and so that's kind of what I like to do
so I like to play like just cunty
monsters because that's what I would
have been had I not um
you know gotten emotionally sober but
also I uh I also think that there's kind
of a that's what I would have been had I
not got my shit together and that I got
all that honestly and it's so fun and I
forgive that person and you love them
and like that's really the the and women
don't it's also a celebration of
I've tried to be perfect for so long yes
that I love the idea of just being like
a messy asshole yes
that's what I'm saying like many people
who play those villains they spend weeks
being like well I have to learn to love
this person I'm like I love her on the
page but now that I know that the most
abusive people have been heard like now
that I know that the most hurt people
are the ones that hurt people the most
that that makes me root for the person
and I can like dig in and justify their
behavior 100 you know so that's even
more fun it's not just like sadistic for
no reason no you can justify it and the
justification is so fun because I
remember being an asshole and all the
like loops and whirly worlds yeah to
like do to make yourself feel good at
the end of the day all the personal
justifications you had to make and that
to bring that to a character it's so
complicated and yummy and it's also a
little bit of you know for us like
there's something healing about being
like this is who you think I am anyway
yeah you know what I'm saying this is
you already think I'm a cunty bitch
who's what I like yeah then why not play
in that space because I spend so much
time I'm not that person and it's like
you you're gonna think what you're gonna
think regardless of my behavior so like
you already think I'm a bitch and I will
think it's say that it's funny because
if you were to go find yourself doing
that and I just recently wrapped a show
the Usher show I can't say that about it
follow the House of Usher puts me in
that space and I was like delightful I
get to just be full cunty bitch like
Kate who put up all of her uh coping
mechanisms and none of her compassion
and then when I watch it
it's not what we think it is it doesn't
come across like that at all because
that's not what you see what you see is
somebody trying their hardest not to
connect and it's heartbreaking we're
taking a little bit of a break uh to
talk about the uh tour I'm about to
embark on I'm going to be uh an October
21st and 23rd in San Jose California San
Jose Improv uh November 3rd I'll be in
Kansas yeah at the Prairie Band Casino
Resort baby mayetta Kansas you cannot
send me offers when I'm on NyQuil God
damn it
November 17th and 19th I'll be in
Sacramento California at the Sacramento
punch line I'm actually these are
opportunities to see me in really small
venues when I'm working on new stuff
about trans people I love November 25th
and 26th I'll be in Phoenix Arizona at
stand up Live December 9th through 11th
I'll be in Oxnard California Wait
December 9th or 11th oh we might do an
only fans roasted on the 11th actually
because that's when cigar can be
available which means that might
okay uh Oxnard Liberty Live I will be
there in December and then February 10th
to 14th I'll be in Irvine California uh
at the Irvine Improv So speaking of
Improv
let's put it to bed your bedroom yes
I prom can we please put it to Ben
because they put me to sleep
[Applause]
so thuma yep uh is this incredible
company uh that will help you elevate
the most important room in your home
they have something called the bed by
Suma it's handcrafted by eco-friendly
high quality upcycled wood you'll find
beautiful unique variations in the
natural grain and you know we love to
get granular natural
yeah when you look at me of first thing
people think it's natural same
yeah they might think like wood finish
the minimalist design also not me yeah
featuring Japanese joinery that's you
that Japanese yeah so here's the deal
beds look I am basically the grandpa
from Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
that's true I live in my bed it's the
most important part of my life your bed
ha people are like running around
willy-nilly trying to figure out their
insomnia issue it's your bed is the
problem and the perfect platform bed
frame just got better you can now
customize the bed by choosing between
our original pillow board or our new
solid wood headboard the fabric pillow
board adds softness and color to any
space while headboard offers solid Sleek
support the headboard attaches directly
to the bed using Japanese joinery with
no tools required buy it with the bed or
on its own as an upgrade along with the
bed thuma offers other bedroom
Essentials to elevate bedtime the
mattress the nightstand and the side
table are perfect complements to the bed
I love it so dramatic I know create that
feeling of checking into your favorite
hope boutique hotel suite but at home
with the bed by thuma and now go to
thuma.com good to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping in the continental US go
to thuma.com
good for a 25 credit and this is not Uma
Thurman's company correct correct back
to the show this is what I sort of like
landed on
yesterday with you because I was like I
was trying to replay high school and re
and like because there's so much to
unpack that and there's so much healing
to be done with us
but I um
I was like oh the scariest people are
the most scared yes like that like it's
a generalization but in general if I
move forward in my life like that life
gets so much easier and better yeah when
you're like oh
if I'm scared of you it means you're
scared like let me just default to that
exactly it helps so much like get rid of
that because you and I have like very
much a similar fight flight Fawn
mechanism response where it is
listen I grew up with with
oh she might watch this
um
no I can't I I can't I love my mom too
much
well good love and
um I feel like
I feel like we should get to the part
that's not our fault yay
can we get to the blame portions
did we get to the victim portion of this
so Kate and I also and I think that like
right right now I feel like this is I
love you so much I'm I know I'm sorry I
know it's like it's making me I know
it's are you nervous are you okay yeah
yeah okay what are you nervous about oh
just I just huh this makes me sad oh
about our teacher yeah yeah our bad bad
teacher yeah it's first of all
awesome we're okay and this person is
sick and perpetrators were probably
victims and some you know that's the
science we do know
um but I I think there's something
really fascinating about talking about
right now this is the kind of shit that
like doesn't ever fly what I will say is
that when we were in high school even in
college like it wasn't weird to date
your professor when I it wasn't the I
dated a much older guy when I was in
high school that you know I feel like
it's weird to talk about now because you
know for a lot of reasons but when in
the South I'm generalizing but in the
South and in lower income families the
idea of dating an older guy with money
is not creepier than
dating a 16 year old who has nothing
who's just going to show everyone photos
of you naked and not know how to fuck
you know what I mean if you're you know
I feel like I was a little bit of
predatory of like oh this guy has a car
and this guy has books and this guy you
know like I want to learn something from
this person because I want to know how
to get out of whatever situation I'm in
yeah I think
I see that point of view very very
clearly mine was a little different yeah
that's that's not most people's yeah I
think that's a singular experience for
me I think that's a great experience for
you and a great way to kind of
put it in your brain and take some of
the power back and take your ownership
of it I think that's a great way to do
it because I was a victim when I was a
child absolutely you understand your
victimhood but this was not that for you
and by the time I was older as a
teenager I was like men are like this I
don't believe this now as an adult all
men are like this sex doesn't really
matter to me that's it's never been
special to me I've I'm an object I try
to be an object I want to be an object
at the time I wanted to be an object
yeah I was starving myself I was like
you know on Accu I wanted to be a sex
object in a way to men
like literally this was she's here long
time in the making still in like a like
the most important part in the room
you are the horror Queen
but do you have please for a like
villain role like the reveal of her just
going back to her bedroom and just
brushing her robot's hair it's actually
a great choice
no no discussion no it's just there it's
just that's really good so yeah so I say
all this as I'm going into like we are I
look at this from a lot of different
dimensions and I know that everyone's
experience a different context is
different just as different generations
of people are listening to this I just
want you guys to know that this is you
know at the time it was murky and before
us it was like murky you know not a
teacher not a person in a position of
power I mean dating older guys like was
something that was
uh at the time not as looked at I'm
bombing with this this isn't this isn't
no yeah no it's not yeah no it's not it
was never okay and it's always weird and
I know I'm so sorry
in here but I don't but I don't want to
break your heart it's like this is how I
defend my parents choice of nothing you
need to live your life with yourself you
need to figure out how to do that and
that's great totally but like whatever
gaslighting Mind Games I played on
myself to make it okay but my takeaway
from this is I did not feel like uh
victim in that scenario yeah that's good
you know what I'm saying I think that's
great I think you lucked out in that way
yes when examining it you were like oh I
actually had more power than I thought
and you felt kind of relieved I think
that is a unicorn experience and then in
interesting and then in retrospect I go
but I learned all this stuff and he had
a he had a he worked at a restaurant so
I learned about how to I would not be a
professional actor without that teacher
and that to me is some of the most
heartbreaking parts of it but you're
making me realize something which is
just because something
two things can be true at once something
can have benefited you your adversity
and have been wrong of course and we as
humans should be able to hold that like
right now they tell us we can't that
there's black and white and canceled and
not canceled and if a older man even
looks at a 20 year old girl it's a
fucking disaster yeah but it can also be
both right like there is no way that I
would be the person sitting here in this
chair without that teacher he also was
unbelievably inappropriate with me
without ever laying a hand on me yeah
and it is it's so complicated it's so
murky it's so hard to reconcile and even
now saying these things I start to get
nauseous me too he starts to be like but
Kate you know and the truth of the
matter is it was all the things it was
all the unequipped to handle it and so
you and I we were in these this class or
I don't even remember a class like it
was just me and you in a room I feel I
don't remember other people around I
just remember
we did like a stage combat scene where
true you and I literally physically
fought each other like like literally
like not only pitted against each other
stuff like he would when I was alone
with him he would talk about you you
know I don't know what happened when I
wasn't around like but it was a a lot of
try to make me jealous of you and I feel
like I was competing with you for his
attention whether I made that up or not
I like needed his attention so bad and a
big part of what he did to me was shame
me for not being mature enough like he'd
be like you're being immature that's not
mature and then it was a lot of you're
an old soul and I think that what these
people do man women whatever is that
they will
whether they're rationalizing to
themselves or to you like you're not as
young as you are there's a lot of that
and they know that your biggest desire
is the 16th is to be mature but I was
taken seriously a 16 year old like I was
not but you wanted to be taken seriously
as an adult all I wanted was to be
mature but it's the adult's job to know
that that's what young people want and
to to not participate in it you're
allowed to be in love with me and I'm
not gonna allow Mr Whitman
fucking beast yep madly nailed it nailed
it not nailed it I was obsessed with him
every girl was in love with him in love
with him he wouldn't even make eye
contact with us never hung out we never
got to call him by his first name no he
would barely chaperone dances because he
knew he knew bear that responsibility
yes and that was amazing and this was a
different teacher this was a different
teacher just for clarity yes so he would
play active defense on if you're an
authority figure right and he was just
another teacher at your school yes okay
but he was like I mean he he was just
the greatest greatest yeah and I
attribute a lot of
how I think is a comedian to him he was
AP History teacher and he would always
make us make links oh absolutely he was
a great teacher so you know what I say
everything has always happened to just
looked different right that was him so
he would go like this happened when has
this happened before in history and what
had happened before and the history
keeps repeating itself so that comes
from him and um
you know so this teacher like really I
think got off on us
being a bad teacher I'm so sorry you're
right she knows what I mean and right
everyone else doesn't so it's really
important that I'm clear thank you and
so we did this like stage combat scene
and I'm looking at it it was very
intricate it was very
in depth because we were very hard
working and we wanted to get it right
but think about how weird it is two
girls were like physically grappling
it's I know I know it's really hard
thinking really hard and then we did in
front of the Soul he made us do it in
front of the whole school and we wanted
to like this is the thing because we
were in a stage combat class it was part
of our theater curriculum and the reason
it felt weird was because of the witness
because there are plenty of stage combat
curriculums where we could have learned
a lot about this art form that had
nothing to do with the feeling we were
all having it's like who is the Supreme
Court Justice who says you know it's
porn when you see it oh I don't know but
it's a thing yeah the difference between
art and porn is you know it's porn when
you see it there is no line and the
reason and this is why this whole thing
is so messy because I don't have like
any example of when he crossed a
physical line you just knowing you're
wrong because I felt it
and that's why that scene was wrong
because under the tutelage of the Mr
Whitman of acting teachers we would have
learned a lot about stage combat we
would have had fun it would have been
safe but it was something about it that
was sexually charged yes 100 have to be
and it shouldn't have been and maybe we
even wanted that because we were little
girls and we were like what is power and
sex and like you know you were wasted I
was starving yeah that's true blood
sugar yeah I was like when can I get out
and sneak a cigarette so oversexed
according to the Headmaster
um and so it but what it ends up being
is
a lot of awkward sitting with
tons and tons of different points of
view it is also not our job at 16 to
have boundaries it is your it is your
job to test boundaries and we're being
taught boundaries and he and like one of
the cruelest things I think he did
was he was always one step ahead of you
me with saying like well you know I'm an
evil man
I'm a dark man and I was like there's
nothing I want more than the permission
to be evil but also if you proceed I
already told you what I'm made of so
it's not my fault and you'll understand
this because you're so mature
I hate that shit I hate sorry can I ask
how old he was it doesn't matter but how
do you remember how old he was somewhere
around 40. okay I think
early 40s okay yeah maybe and also
bewitching and beguiling and charming
and like seemingly floated through like
just the most elegant and also I'm gonna
say something that's gonna get me in
some trouble
um but it's important because there was
also an odd androgyny that protected him
where it was like I no one was really
sure well he often talked about
collecting students and he would want to
collect men and collect women it wasn't
that he just wanted you me and Mara but
totally but there was a little bit of uh
in that order
probably yeah in that order you're the
number one he wanted you the most no I I
I'm half joking when I say like kind of
a big part of the trauma with me and him
is I felt rejected by him yeah I left
there being like I didn't get him yeah
like that's how fucked up that's how
entrenched in that I wasn't thin enough
I wasn't pretty enough I wasn't as
talented as Kate now I have to go
through the world like this is someone
that when I think about like who am I
trying who am I doing all this for is
this for me is this for my dad is from
like whose approval do I want and I
think about his approval like I've had
to unwind him from my brain because like
all you know when your therapist asks
you like whose voice is that who are you
doing that for more often than not at
the beginning my answer was his name
which is by the way there's no of course
it just is what it is and like the
Stockholm syndrome of it and also the
knowing how badly we wanted something
yeah and how desperate we were to get it
yeah and then him
sort of masquerading as the person that
could give it to us and provide it for
us you know that was even like was so
sick
were you Abigail in The Crucible or did
I make that up no it's true front row
I'm literally like
your version of Googling me whatever 10
years ago was me pre-google when we were
on like I was just staring at you
playing Abigail from The Crucible and
was just like but it's so it's so wild
to just also think about like how
inappropriate inherently a lot of that
stuff was which you know I know there's
a lot of theater programs and
um athletic programs and stuff that are
getting in trouble now or like a lot of
the behaviors being revealed because a
lot of things in the acting curriculum
is just inherently inappropriate 16 year
old you know playing Nora's from the a
doll's house at yeah it's 15 like the
good news is you kind of don't unders I
just didn't even understand what I was
doing I was pretending to pretend I was
acting like you know but a lot of what's
chosen isn't is just inherently
inappropriate because it's always so
sexually charged right like well because
theater is very like they love that
Dynamic there are only so many times you
can do Fiddler on the Roof right totally
yeah everything is about sex or Nazis
yeah you know what I mean so it's kind
of like you know know it's just an
inappropriate subject matter like in
general yeah so it's like you know I
think that that that's another thing
where I'm like oh like because when I
try to get my abusers off the hook which
is something that I really
am not sure if I need to work on it or
not but I sort of need to forgive my
abusers it's just like a current okay
um thing I'm
addicted to doing like we forgive others
not because they deserve forgiveness but
because we deserve peace we love an AAA
moment it's just I love an a moment it's
just for me yeah forgiveness isn't for
them no and it's you are the one who
gets to heal yourself there is no
handbook there is no like these are the
steps to feeling okay with your trauma
you get to do it any fucking way you
want if that involves forgiving
everybody yay if that involves forgiving
no one hurray and I think for me it's
just something that is like very uh
because
I don't know why I need to do that it
might be me sort of being cerebral about
my denial I might just have a lot of
denial this is also a really fun
conversation because we're both still in
the middle of it like I would say that
neither of us like seeing each other
again and like the voice memos we shared
back and forth and like the the like
gift and The Crucible of like having
someone else who was there it brings
everything up so we are having it right
now there's no way that we can have any
perspective on this situation it's our
first conversation about it ever and
here's what's odd about it I can forgive
him for what he did to me but I can't
for what he to do like I can't forgive
him for what he did to other people
that's interesting which is I think
there's some self-limiting belief or
narrative that's like I can take it like
do it to me but don't do it like you
deserved it but I didn't think that
you're putting on yourself which isn't
true because I don't forgive him for
what he did to you me or any of my
friends because I think I was like I've
already been molested so that ship
sailed yeah me too my yeah my heart was
not like that this was a totally
different thing this was a reprogramming
of the brain this was an intentional
like shuffling of the personality of a
child and that has lasted my whole life
has lasted your whole life and that to
me is beyond forgiveness yeah
I accept it it happened but like and for
me there's like
it has tentacles in my life in the sense
that like
I would spend time with him outside of
school and my mom would tell me later
like your dad hated that man I hated
that man I was like then why the fuck
did you let me go to his house yeah yeah
like you saw me sneak out and you
couldn't stop me drive to the fucking
house and come get me like what the fuck
yeah yeah yeah and like but that's not
their fault they didn't know I didn't
know I think that's why I'm going like I
forgive my parents for not doing
something about this like older men
Predator thing because either they had
to tell themselves a bunch of lies to
rationalize like yeah or yeah or the
idea that it was untoward was so they
can't accept it it just wasn't even on
the menu of thoughts like it wouldn't
even cross it wouldn't even cross
someone's mind who isn't sick to worry
about that yeah and I do think there's a
certain
I like that really hard to like think of
this in a linear way because I'm like
having it right I'm having a moment
um but what it what helps me in moments
like this and like Mantra moments like
this is people did the best they could
at the time yeah my parents are the best
liquor at the time and I guess this
person also did the best he could at the
time like maybe he's like you said
fucked it doesn't mean I have to forgive
anybody but like and I know I did the
best and I think that you and I probably
did a really good job of keeping secrets
from our primary characters 100 they
were we
they were operating on the data they got
from us and we're very good actresses
you said I was brilliant you are
brilliant you heard it first you are
brilliant it's it's I'm still I'm
allowed to be jealous of your talent and
not you I'm jealous of your talent I'm
allowed to be jealous I think there's a
I I'm obsessed with healthy jealousy and
healthy competition Chelsea versus Envy
explain that that's right Envy's the sin
right Envy is like and not you don't
have to believe in God to digest this I
fucking love that saying you just said
it yeah taking it forever Envy is the
thing where you want to take it from
somebody you don't want them to have it
anymore because you love it so much
jealousy is the recognition that
something else is fucking awesome
awesome and I'd like some of it but like
I don't I don't want to take away your
talent I'm just like that's a gorgeous
talent and I love it and it makes me
want to do that but like if it was Envy
I'd want to remove your brain from your
beautiful little skull and then digest
it and like become second zombie Whitney
but this is
I am please take
um this is blowing my mind
um
this is blowing my mind so I yeah I was
thinking uh there's a scene the scene in
Hill House where uh you're at your
sister Victoria uh pedretti's characters
uh funeral and it is the most Neil Le
beaut fucking genius scene that is just
per any other director would you like
this is going on too long but it's like
yeah it's playing in real time and is
someone that is like I mean obviously
that's a very it's a different reality
I've been through like at real food this
is how weird and specific it is and how
long it goes on
um and you just made some of the most
fucking I literally like was like come
on like some of the most brilliant
choices thank you that were so like
funny and real and specific and you and
I guess it's also like to me
I I I'm happy for us because not only
did we make it we made it doing what we
wanted to do
you know because I think both of us
could have been you know in some reality
if I was a little more like compliant or
like less insecure in auditions and you
know worked out more I could have been
on How I Met Your Mother once or twice
if I was able to control you could have
been the wife in Shaggy Dog I've wow I'd
love to you know what I mean yeah we
could totally be like absolutely the
wife that doesn't want sex who kind of
hates their husbands on a sitcom like we
could have done that 100 well I've tried
but they wouldn't let me yeah
and thank you and thank you thank you
for not hiring me for that yeah
absolutely thank you for not putting me
on like a shitty sitcom for nine years
thank you for not
um casting me in fucking whatever the
CSI Pensacola because I would be on that
for 10 years and you know like you got
to do what you do and shine in a way
that I think very few people get to God
I I feel incredibly Lucky in that way I
was um so my husband and I worked
together and we were just about to go we
were in New York going back for his next
show and I was just thinking about that
that I I carry a lot around a lot of
shame that I work with my husband like
people think I only got this job because
I'm fucking the director which I am but
um
well you've been married how long like
seven years okay so are you no well yes
I am I really am
three to four times a week thing that's
very important you're oversized I'm
oversized student principle
play Everything never stop acting never
I know I have I have a wide exciting and
varied sex life
um
but I I am the opposite so I I don't
think that's the I don't I get it I
don't buy it I don't buy it because then
you're
it works once right like he gets to put
me in something once and then what
people don't know and this is the same
argument with nepotism babies and so
like I get it it's like but it's also
the reason he married you yeah you
didn't collaborated and we did the whole
thing but like what people don't
understand is acting is not like
becoming a pediatrician it's not like
you go to school for four years then six
years and you do a residency and then
you get your thing everyone's path is
fucking different yeah everyone gets in
a different way everyone is hustling
everyone's working hard like we said
there's no actress here who's Like
Somebody's Daughter who's just sitting
on her couch and like the producers walk
in and like you're the one Emily in
Paris is you yeah like she hustled her
fucking ass off and she only gets one CH
like maybe she did get an extra first
chance sure but but also
um what uh like there's many things that
annoy me about that but I would yeah
Please Release that shame because I
think I go the reason he married her is
because she's the type of person he
would want to put in all of her movies
as an app you would be in his movies
regardless he just lucked out and
marrying you well we just fell in love
like we didn't mean to but there's a
delivery oh
we have a surprise uh guest
is it Bobby Kohler
you fucking witch because everybody
talks about how cool Bobby Kohler is now
[Laughter]
I am furious that you know this you
everyone talks about how cool Bobby if
it was Les schwerzinski that's when you
would have won Lesh warzinski
Bobby Kohler is here Bobby Kohler it
went to high school with us
can you grab this home sit next to me
again also yeah you can sit there if you
want god
um I'm traveling where do you want him
to go just sit right there yeah yeah you
can just sit right there so Bobby Kohler
again only character look at me he's not
even looking at me did you guys hook up
the fact that the fact that you guys are
doing this for fun is like insanity it's
also like a tracks completely with high
school though like this is the shit we
would have done versus psychotic yeah
you guys like want to go back and relive
the things that everyone's trying to put
behind them and I'm like so thankful
that we didn't have social media or
Instagram oh that's true like I feel
like I just detangled my Trauma from
high school and like I should be on like
an Alcoholics Anonymous like list of
people to be like hey man sorry about
this sorry about that oh yeah and then
you guys like are like come in do a
podcast that'll be a great cathartic way
to like relive your past
but what we're doing is like forgiving
ourselves for what we did to almost to
ourselves not only to each other but
like to ourselves I also find it very
strange to hear Bobby Kohler's voice
coming out of your face it's what was
your perception of us in high school oh
my god oh man I think that my perception
of you guys was I always thought I
thought Whitney was like
trying to run a Fortune 500 company at
AutoZone
I'm like she's showing up with like a
Starbucks and coffee and like fully a
type ready to go and we're just like
trying to figure out who we were and
then Katie transferred him isn't that so
wild because the first thing I said was
like you always showed up with a
Starbucks I started doing it because she
showed up at the Starbucks one day and I
was like just needed something well she
transferred in and she was like the cool
kid from public school nightmare yeah
you kind of like you know do you
remember us being friends
because she said we were kind of friends
in the beginning and then I don't
totally remember that
what happened was I became really close
with Mara and EB and that just changed
everything yeah and that became like a
little coven of three yeah like that got
so weird because Mara had been to school
forever and Elizabeth been in school
forever and they had a group of five but
I was just like I'd never had female
friends before okay Laura and EB like
changed my life shut up Bobby Kohler
Noah knows who I am and it's literally
like they're like who is this dude why'd
you bring him on the show
it's so hilarious to me that are because
something I talk about is our perception
of ourselves how we perceive ourselves
versus how other people perceive
ourselves it's the thing I wrote about
my book the uh what's your favorite
animal your favorite article clothing
the whole that exercise is all about
understanding how you're perceived by
others versus how you think you're
perceived because we are all so
dysmorphic in the way we I will say this
is very similar like Bobby and I would
end up at a lot of parties together at
the end of the night and me and Mara and
Evie would be talking about shit like
this and Bobby would be like why the
fuck are we talking about and here's the
other thing about you I was so not
self-aware that I look back and I'm like
oh you were like the funniest person in
school and were hilarious with like like
what I now do is like roast jokes and
observational but I yeah You observe
things that I didn't understand I was
giving off so I didn't even realize how
funny you were I just thought you were
me wait sorry I have to address one more
thing that you just reminded me of which
was that you were saying that when you
were hanging out with older dudes it was
better because they were talking about
real stuff and reading books what you
missed out on was like the Saint Andrews
guys were actually really fucking great
like I had some of the best
conversations of my life with chess
Garrison like I beat me for class
president he was a wonderful class
president you would have been very bad
at that job yeah I wore a dress from
Urban Outfitters famous model Whitney
you didn't have the time I didn't even
look at Whitney I didn't even look at
Whitney as a model though I looked at
her as a just a really Elite athlete
like and just effortless you know real
and I tell people that you know people
like I was like I went to school with
Winnie and you know she was I don't
really remember like acting per se I
think that was later on and then comedy
like wait comedy came out of right field
you know but but Athletics I was like oh
she could have played like you know like
our school was like at the time very at
Athletics and very good at liberal arts
and I think that you with the right
nurturing
um you know it's like easily D1 you know
basketball you could have just it just I
think we were all like Hey we're happy
it's a participation thing happy to be
here with sports whereas like you know
the drama and the liberal arts side of
things we were graduating as you two sit
here successful and then there's Evan
and other people that like came out of
it and I um had to I think that for me
basketball I wanted to do that but then
my eating disorder eclipsed it like I
just couldn't keep competing High School
boys are though it's like oh when you
had to eat and disorder just like guys
that's why he's not in tune with
anything that was going on I think like
we were a little slow but also we were
I'll speak for myself here I was also
very cunning and conniving like there
was I pulled it off well I mean I
tricked the eating disorder therapist
like you know like I could trick anyone
with it and that's what's so Insidious
about that disease but it's very
isolating and I was talking to Mara
yesterday and I was like I'm so sorry
that I came off so aloof it was I was
just so scared that people would find
out or
um reveal me in some way or want to eat
I hope this gives you
um comfort and it doesn't make you feel
called out I don't think you were as
subtle as you think you were that's
what's fascinating I was getting away
with none of it I don't know if you're
getting away with none of it like you
tricked a counselor you tricked a
counselor but
I think we all kind of like
kids are less
helpful than adults and so it was like
oh yeah Whitney doesn't eat and it
didn't occur like we don't have a
concept of Eating Disorders right right
like this but I'm like yeah I know
Whitney doesn't eat she's really fucking
skinny she's a model I don't know and
like I don't like yeah she's not at
lunch like we didn't go out to dinner
like we weren't around and but it never
I wouldn't have put two and two together
because I was a child and so I don't
know if you were getting away with it
the way you think you were but
I think it was just
the aloofness came like what didn't come
across was your insecurity
but interesting you were into something
was going clearly something was going on
at least like the chicks knew like girls
knew I think a lot of insecure people
come off very confident like I've gotten
this a lot in my life it's kind of my
lot in life to be like so scared in a
situation or uncomfortable or like
socially anxious and like worried that
I'm gonna say something stupid or make
people not like me and then people like
oh I just thought you're a bitch that's
so weird because I just wanted you to
like me you know it's such an in like I
don't know how to get I'm like really
working on changing what I give off when
I'm saying nothing I really hope that
somebody watches this podcast because I
think it's really interesting many
people will watch it I don't know man
they're gonna be like who are these guys
you realize that celebrity like no one
cares about like this is the shit this
is like real this is the shit I'm
telling you you talked about the drama
teacher for a while yeah did you guys
like like was that something that was I
mean we have a group text threads about
it yeah it's just like pretty I mean
it's pretty gnarly add Whitney to that
group text thread yeah we can okay I
mean listen yeah add me I will yeah I
don't know I feel like there's a lot of
the the 90s is like as you see these
documentaries come out the Von Dutch
thing the Britney Spears thing you know
you see Abercrombie yeah like the
toxicity that was we were like
permeating through the media and then we
were just living it as we were like this
is how it's supposed to be you know all
of these big movements happened you know
way too late and we kind of were just
winging it and and it kind of left us to
a weird place to like not really be
observant or protective of our fellow
classmates you know it wasn't an open
and honest thing where someone like
could get canceled it wasn't like oh
that's that behavior is off like we need
to out this dude and like you know but
we did do you guys remember we did
this no I don't remember the show okay
um I know what you're thinking
I've been listening to Winnie Cummings
talk for the past hour I'm pulling my
hair out I'm going bald with stress
she's giving me a bald spot yeah with
her dirty computer screen and sure last
voice okay we joke but naturally over
half of women will experience hair
thinning in their lifetime that's why I
use neutral full look at dude I know
it's luscious I look at my ponytail it's
literally it's like a horse tape I
litter I have I look like Theo Vaughn up
until like a year ago I use neutrophil
it's clinically effective and natural
supplement and basically like I don't
know I'm just at the point in my life
where I'm like if I was gonna get it for
my food I would have this the stress of
trying to find a food that's gonna have
Biotin and all the nutrients I need is
what's making me go bald with this right
yeah the very thing
that you're trying to accomplish is
backfiring and stressing you out right I
noticed driving because I'm driving
around all the time like because La
traffic's so bad I noticed in my
rearview mirror like my the top layer
like the top of my head was Getting
Thinner and I was like oh hell no so I
started
I love this like 180 on Emily that now I
am like we need to cut that okay
how did these rolls reverse so quickly
no we're keeping it okay let's talk
about it you're a hairstory your history
could help another woman join the
conversation at shed the silence.com
that's shed the silence.com so
um I want to talk about
um life
and how it's tough and full of difficult
questions and frankly I as I said that I
did try to put my elbow down and miss
so what is happiness really mean how do
I get the most out of my time on Earth
even though I've been dead for 15 years
how many hours is too many hours to play
video games per day these are the
questions that host Justin Long seeks to
solve on his podcast life is short with
Justin Long Justin is hilarious he's
brilliant he's super insightful so if
you're looking for an answer to these
deep philosophical questions about the
meaning of life Justin is so funny you
know he believes that we enrich our
experience by learning from others and
that's why in each episode he chats with
celebrities actors musicians artists and
more about how they get the most out of
their life their conversations explore
how they felt during their highs and
more importantly lows in their careers
which is why I have not done the podcast
because it would be nine hours long if
it was just about Lowe's you'll learn
about those little tricks they employ to
stay happy during the hard times but if
I'm being honest this podcast is mostly
just hilarious chats between friends and
stupid stuff like why can't you wear
socks with sandals listen to life is
short with Justin Long on Apple podcast
Amazon music or listen ad free by
joining wondery Plus in the wondery app
back to my show genuinely I was always
so insecure that I was dumb that I
genuinely wanted to learn stuff like I
was also kind of a dork and I would like
the classes were like 48 minutes or
whatever at 47 minutes I'd be like
um so what did that mean like should I
thought we were gonna do a quiz today
and everyone would be like I do remember
that yes I was like this is such a dork
like I was the person because I couldn't
I wouldn't eat lunch so I'm like let's
stay here and learn and then at lunch I
would just hang out with Lee Stitzer I
mean my bat my least answer I was like
friends with the goth girl like that was
my shit the best her and I would just
like hang out and smoke
Lindsay share was also my uh friend I
loved it when Lindsey share was a sex
advice radio host I did not know that
was my favorite like incantation of
Lindsay share can I tell you something
like probably as writers like writers
actors whatever to think about I love
job like specific she now makes living
walls I love that too and I want one so
do I and she was delivering fresh fruit
for a while like had a service that was
like delivering fresh fruit I didn't
know about the sex therapy I will say
this though like thinking through it a
lot of people have very specific and
excellent careers like Mara makes
jewelry her jewelry is legitimately like
simple I'm saving up for one of those
beetles I freaking love it
um
Mar green jewelry check it out uh but
like Lindsay share doing that you doing
music like Lesh is a very famous
musician cool
um Colin Taylor's a Headmaster Tom this
is exactly I mean what is that even the
right sex a lot of dicks no he's the can
we say out of school no it's that's
you're not the head of school head of
school right
now these are no there's we can but I'm
big on the show about going that was the
term until it we now know it's wrong but
if we don't talk about what it used to
be use it but it's not great yeah but I
think like saying master bedroom you're
not supposed to say master bedroom but
most people don't like they get to learn
that great and not embarrass themselves
at work but that is a perfect career for
Tom Taylor yeah he was basically like
our parent of the class as well you know
and that's a lot of responsibilities
chess is I think in politics I think
chess is in politics chess is going to
be such a good politician yeah that's
wild the best actor of all turns out
um what okay I feel like I'm putting you
on this bottom sorry I hope I didn't get
you in trouble
I don't know I mean they'll see like it
wouldn't occur to me that someone would
want privacy in their life in any
capacity oh yeah I'm just like this is
going to open up something that I don't
even know like because I don't know that
there was a kid stalking like you got
stalked right by someone at school I got
stalked a bunch of kids got stalked by a
kid that was under us and like in the
world that we live in yeah like there's
people that probably really dislike all
of us potentially from high school and
it's just like I've experience it's
crazy if you can't beat up your own
stalker you don't deserve to be famous
yeah but stalker's just hot take they go
straight to the
AR-15s these days oh yeah I do the
different speed this world we grew up in
a world where it was like columbine one
right right and you're just like wow now
it's just like kids
socials guns in schools Roe v Wade like
I mean not the the this generation of
high school kids is just like that's the
other thing that's the other thing and I
think that that's why this is like so
relatable because it's it's not over you
know what I'm saying it's not this still
happens just it just looks different you
know it's like a a different kind of
trauma for people currently in high
school like so yeah I think it's just
important to like talk about these like
you know how important it is to just
lean into your female friendships and
have compassion for people you're in
high school with because like don't wait
20 years to figure this out but also
there's something we said about like the
depth of connection we were able to make
20 years ago that I'm still stoked to
see Bobby Kohler right now and like talk
about this and like all of these people
you cannot or Zoom you cannot make new
old friends exactly you just can't and I
was a big fan of like burn a bridge
never look back because I just was so
scared of hearing things I had said that
had hurt people or whatever but in
reality you don't it's not what the
conversation is really about after a
point it's about these points of
connection that were real and like where
I just read something recently it says
you don't make friends like the friends
you made when you were 15 well ever
again well it's just not like that like
I would remember these nights where I
would like we would all pile into this
bed in Evie's basement and we would lay
there like boys girls heads in each
other's laps yeah talking about the
meaning of life and like who the these
people would become yeah and if any of
them walked into this room no matter
what happened I'd be like this is
fucking cool yeah and I would like get
on a plane there's a level of like love
unconditional love went through a lot
together yeah yeah and I think that
there's also like to me there's just
like a high school P that I was hurt
it's like like I think that we all
forgive each other and doing this helps
us forgive ourselves yes and realize
it's not as bad as you thought it was
not as bad as it was in your head and
like you've gone through it and you've
thought about it but when you sit across
from someone you're like oh look look at
you human everything was so traumatic
and such a big deal at the time and we
didn't have right-sized reactions and
you're like of course if it's hysterical
it's historical and we didn't know that
at the time but to now just like oh yeah
that weird thing we had that was like
the biggest deal in the world like that
was just it just happened us being human
beings and if there's this is the first
time in history where people like us can
talk like this have conversations like
this and then next Generation to
thousands of people yeah and yeah and
the Next Generation can listen to it and
go like oh let's cut that time in half
like you don't have to wait 20 years
yeah just like Get over move on like
it's not that big of a deal and like
there's a way to heal faster because I I
think
for for me like
you know and I don't mean to get too
gendered about it but
the difference between men and women
jokes paid for this house so
um I do think there's a a scarcity
complex that you and I were both very
um
you know fell victim to of this like
it's mere you and we're competitive with
each other and it could only be one of
us and I had that a lot in comedy also
it was like you know other female
comedians it really was there's only one
girl that's gonna be on a lineup so as
soon as I kind of started to go like oh
maybe the scarcity accomplice thing is a
mirage or maybe this is something that's
like internalized misogyny or whatever
and then I get into comedy and it's true
yeah like it's literally true so it like
made my scarcity complex even worse
because it was like they just need to
check one box to have a girl but the
guys don't fucking do that shit the guys
share they go like I don't even have to
fucking like you dude let's get on the
same team and we'll both win even harder
if we support each other whereas women
tend to go like not give each other
support because if I support you that's
less for me you know but I think that
that we're seeing that that's not
necessarily true and supporting other
women actually everybody wins and the we
just have to think in terms of like
abundance instead of scarcity think
about this a class of 70 and two women
come out of it and just that's the thing
it's like competition maybe it also
I mean there was time when I was crying
about the premiere of Whitney and your
inevitable I was crying too don't worry
but I was like I can't fucking stop now
if I stop now then I'll never beat
Whitney
well it's funny like uh I was on the
phone with Mario yesterday and she was
like yeah like you know I was like I've
just been so jealous of Kate for so long
and she was like well I think we're kind
of jealous of you dude wait so can I
stop now did I win no no 20 years later
I'm like okay did I repeat I think we're
never gonna fucking win but it's also I
think there's like I don't know I I just
I'm so grateful for it now like in so
many ways I think that again because our
job is to overthink things and pick
things apart and we have such big
haunted definitely beat me like a
hundred percent you created so many TV
shows if your own specials on Netflix
and you have two gorgeous children and
amazing husbands I do have a good
husband yeah you you have balance in
your life and you're also doing what
exactly what you wanted to do and you
were made in a lab to do what you're
doing
wow like it's good it is so fucking
impressive you're not on these like
dumps you're not just a working actress
you are like
living to the top of your potential and
I believe that in the in the
performances I've seen you do in these
shows no one could do them better and
it's just so fun to watch you not having
to play beneath your intelligence level
or
beneath what you're capable of
and it's so fun to watch this has been a
remarkably healing conversation
um
I remember thinking so early on when you
came out as a comedian because we all
knew you was kind of this Fortune 500
CEO feeling thing being like what do you
mean she's so fucking funny and I would
listen to your bits and I would watch
you and like on shows and like on late
night and then your specials and be like
how fucking lucky like on top of
everything else she was like a secret
comic genius oh gosh outside and like
you really you take all of it all of
what has been like traumatic and like
the slings and arrows about rage's
fortune and you turn them into these
like beautiful tiny like glass animals
of humor that you then Smash and like
that full synthesis it's so rare and
brave I hope do you hear that a lot yeah
I hope you hear that a lot that you are
rare and brave
Bobby's fine
is by the way this is one of the braver
things I've seen anyone do is just walk
in this room and start fighting about
abortion it's really fucking impressive
I'm up for it I really like all of you
that is our liberal arts education and
then you like is it's wild because it's
like I do think people look at Comedians
and they're like you're so brave and you
take so many risks and to me it's like
this is the safest choice because uh
comedy for someone that's attracted to
doing it it's how we can basically we
become comedians to control how we're
embarrassed yep you know what I'm saying
I understand that this is the same like
me being on stage with like a security
guard that makes it so no one's allowed
to talk back like this to me is the
safest way it's I'm not taking a risk at
all in a lot of ways acting is the most
humiliating thing I've ever done I am so
fucking Blown Away by how like
vulnerable and Beyond Brave you are in
your work well the feelings Mutual it
like it it is like a horror like all
your their horror shows on many levels
I'm like oh my God and she's just crying
and there's no Cuts she'll never cut
yeah
okay so this is just a real just for
everyone not only are these most
performances are cut together in post to
make well when good when you
um watch these shows look at how few
cuts are on Kate's performances these
are eight minutes straight it's not she
had nine takes and in between all the
takes that's what happened this is like
totally uncut it's true he does love to
let me just run it's and it goes back to
the teacher like I've had a series of
problematic teachers who made me into an
actress and with one is there another I
don't know whatever but thank you for
noticing that I that's something I'm
particularly proud of like no cuts no
Cuts it's eight minutes no cuts and this
is still a fucking flat like it's I'm
just I'm totally Blown Away by you I I
feel like I picked the right person to
be jealous of okay okay I was I was
right this whole time I'm proud of
myself for being jealous of someone that
deserved it
what do you think John Clark is doing
right now
do you know what John Clark is doing
right now Whitney's boyfriend John Clark
the one with his hair part in the middle
it was no he was like he had a perfect
jaw on his parents whenever home
that sounds like trouble if you're a
junior
I went to some dance with him and he
went to he's like super smart he went to
like Carnegie Mellon right did I make
that up no like some really great guy
another one of the really great Saint
Andrews guys like just like a nice guy
didn't fuck around didn't hurt anybody
really smart you know now I'm like this
is my new Kink to like reconnect with
these people from high school and be
like oh like all these people were
looking for in our lives to enrich like
they're they were here this whole time
they're right here it was right in front
of you they're on Facebook they're all I
have to go give my data to Facebook in
order to
reconnect
I love you guys I really I'm I I feel uh
like I didn't nail this but that's okay
no it was great no yeah I think you
nailed it exactly right yeah edit
whatever you want yeah yeah I'm just now
I just want to hang out with you and
it's not a lot of God in this chili is
tonight okay so we're gonna do a
separate episode I'm gonna kidnap her
again and make her come back to just
only talk about your career
um because that was just a lot about our
I think it's great I've been I've that's
what I was hoping for I talk about my
career too much anyway I wanted to talk
about real life shit with you and so I
was like publicist stay home don't want
any of that shit I want to talk to
Whitney and I think it will be an
intelligent conversation and worth other
people watching and then I think it
became exactly that and so I hope you
don't feel like you blew this one yeah I
was like if I'm embarrassed at the end
that means it was good yes we have been
vulnerable and that's important yeah I
think the fact that I'm like in a spiral
means we nailed it
I love you guys Kate Siegel
bobbykoller.com don't ride elephants
[Music]
[Applause]